[Music]
i'm michael burns
welcome to wisecrack
[Applause]
today i want to talk about the tv and
film franchise that kept
emergency rooms full of suburban
millennial teens for much of the early
2000s no not scrubs though
many teens did go to their local
hospitals hoping to witness tweet antics
and psychotic janitors only to leave
sorely disappointed we are of course
talking about jackass
the tv show turned film franchise that
saw a bunch of dudes ask life's big
questions like what if an almost naked
adult man crawled across a floor covered
in mousetraps
how severely can you destroy a rental
car without consequences and
which of your friends has the best sperm
rick's got good sperm
okay so the show is not known for its
explicitly philosophical themes
but we wanted to see if we could
discover some deep themes beneath the
reckless surface
so we decided to give it the full deeper
dumb treatment which is to say
we're going to see if we can present
some interpretations of the show that
will convince you
and to be honest us that jackass is in
fact
deep so let's get into this wisecrack
edition on jackass
deep or dumb and stick around until the
end of the video
because i'm going to be doing a quick q
a session with questions submitted by
our patrons
but now let's get into the video for
those of you who aren't religiously
watching mtv in the early 2000s a quick
refresher the jackass started as a
short-lived show where a crew of dudes
led by johnny knoxville
performed all types of dangerous
disgusting and absurd stunts
filmed in a super low fine manner the
show ended when mtv wouldn't let them
put their best ideas on air
so the team took their talents to your
local cinema and released a series of
films
jackass the movie welcome to jackass
jackass number two
jackass 3d hi i'm johnny knoxville
welcome to jackass
with a fourth film supposedly coming out
later this year
during this run they've tempted fate
with bulls and alligators
used shopping carts wheelbarrows and big
wheels as off-road vehicles
terrorized bargera's parents repeatedly
and spent way more time in
port-a-potties than the entire coachella
going population put together
and sadly it's worth mentioning that
things have not been all fun and games
for the jackass crew with multiple
members struggling with addiction and
ryan dunn tragically dying in a car
accident
to help us in our unlikely journey to
prove jackasses depth we're gonna sort
the show's various antics into three
categories
body humor which is anything involving
poop farts puke piss
self-inflicted tasers etc pranks
throwing flower on your sleeping friends
faces
slapping your friends with a giant hand
trapping your friends in a limo full of
bees
so basically just torturing your friends
and public disruption
skateboarding through tokyo and panda
costumes stripping in an electronic
store hiding a duct taped and naked man
in a trunk so let's get started and see
if we can get real
deep in that jackass let's begin with
body humor
now i know what you're thinking surely
you're not going to try to tell me an
intelligent
worldly and downright gorgeous wisecrack
viewer that there is some hidden
philosophical depth to a grown man
shoving a toy car up his ass or that
watching someone eat a puke omelet
is really a commentary on the mass
reproduction of art and culture
and it probably isn't but hear me out
think about how the human body is
represented in today's media most of the
time it's misleading deceptive and makes
me want to get straight to work on my
8-pack
there is a multi-million dollar industry
creating apps that allow us to alter our
appearances on social media
influencers put tons of time and effort
into staging supposedly
natural photos and whether it's hair
plugs or cheek fillers
almost no one gracing our screens these
days as living in a good old-fashioned
flawed human body
and of course this all is the effect of
making us feel like [ __ ] about ourselves
for not having dewy skin
chiseled abs or a gorgeous mullet but
the jackass boys pull off stunts to
highlight the pure
gross animality of the human form and in
the process
they actually offer a much more honest
and relatable vision of what a normal
human body is actually like
even if you'd never put your own
corporeal form onto an actual
rocket full of explosives being shot
into the sky
and not only do we see raw bodies doing
gross things but we also see the
repercussions and implications of these
stunts for example
when johnny has a mishap trying to do a
roller skate jump over the la river
we follow him to the emergency room and
in later stunts we see him wearing a
soft cast
showing the physical damage done rather
than glamorizing these types of stunts
jackass makes it clear that they are
very dumb and likely to cause injury
because
these are real people with real bodies
except for stevo
who clearly has vibranium bones because
he should absolutely be
dead you can compare this to a standard
action film where heroes jump through
glass windows take a couple of bullets
to the leg drive a car off a bridge
and are still able to walk it off in
time to kiss their inappropriately aged
lover who of course
has perfect hair and makeup after being
held hostage by some vaguely
eastern european bad guys but jackass
reminds us that our bodies don't work
that way
now at this point you might be thinking
that with all the [ __ ] coming out of
my mouth
that i must be doing some sort of
reverse jackass style fecal stunt but
there are actual scholars who think
there is something deep going on here
too
berkeley professor andrew schenken
argues that the myriad ways in which
jackass uses pain corporal transgression
and public humiliation
suggests ties to a more fluid sense of
the body allowing its use as a vehicle
for entertainment even via potentially
harmful behavior to seem more normative
put simply it's funny when people fall
down and the comedic simplicity of
body-based humor is something we should
embrace
and celebrate as shanking goes on to say
jackass carries on the physical humor of
charlie chaplin in an aesthetic mode of
decadence and this might make it
possible for jackass tons to still be
pretty funny 100 years from now
[Music]
redemption much like how the physical
comedy of chaplin the three stooges and
the marx brothers still holds up
so this makes jackass's body humor at
least kind of deep
but if we're honest it's also kind of
dumb i mean watching a grown man pee on
another grown man
and in 3d nonetheless is pretty gross
and some of the penis-based gags tend to
play into dated tropes about male
sexuality and worse
they can seem kind of homophobic also
they led audience members at screenings
of the movies to throw up in their seats
which is definitely not deep but
definitely is funny
let's step away from the flying porta
potties and
desecrated display model toilets and
talk about the very funny and sometimes
brutal pranks the guys pull on each
other
if our attempt to make body humor deep
felt like a reach i think there might be
a more convincing
argument here for why pranks are doing a
lot more than just
ruining phil margera's rem cycle poor
guy well the pranks are of course very
funny
they also inject a sense of surprise and
wonder into otherwise mundane situations
many of the show's best pranks take
place in pretty boring places
like the halls of a bland production
office the back of a van or simply
during downtime while on set and though
they obviously have the budget for
expensive props and effects
the pranks often rely on things most of
us have around the house like a bag of
flowers some super glue
[Applause]
or a stun gun okay probably not the stun
gun
the cruise pranking is built on a
creative ability to turn generic
situations and objects into sites of
possibility and surprise
hi i'm michael burns welcome to
wisecrack
what's more the pranks are almost always
filmed in a way that shows us the
reactions of the cast and crew
we're often hunched over in the type of
laughter that leaves you unable to form
coherent sentences
and i don't think it's going too far to
say that these pranks create moments of
collective joy
for both the prankers the prankies and
us the prank
the audience more so than lots of
comedic entertainment this leaves us
feeling in
on the joke and it's not just joy as we
can feel real
empathy with both the performers being
pranked as i too can imagine what it
would be like to have a small
child kick me in the groin or with the
other guys laughing on the side as i too
can imagine how funny it would be to
watch my friend get kicked in the groin
by a line of children
and even if at times it feels like
they're singling someone out writer
benedict's carey has noted that
practical jokes are far more commonly an
effort
to bring a person into a group
anthropologists have found an integral
part of rituals around the world
intended to temper success with humility
and recent research suggests that the
experience of being duped can stir
self-reflection in a way few other
experiences can
functioning as a check on arrogance or
obliviousness so
i guess pranking our friends can lead to
self-reflection and dare i say
self-examination which i guess makes
jackass a fundamentally philosophic
enterprise
too far yeah but you might be thinking
aren't there pranks sometimes kind of
mean
and you wouldn't be wrong as there are
occasions where the person being pranked
isn't a part of the crew or
in on the joke i have a pretty high
tolerance for the brutality of their
pranks
but even i felt pretty squirmy watching
bamarjera reduced to
tears on the two occasions he gets
trapped in an enclosed space with live
snakes
as a prank at this point i imagine many
of you remain unconvinced that jackass
is in fact
deep but our best chance of changing
that is going to be their stunts that
involve acts
of public disruption these are the parts
of the show where various jackasses
enter a shared public space to uh
mix things up a bit these stunts usually
take a space that's either
private or used for the purpose of
commerce and turn them into spaces of
public performance
transforming a bland business park or
suburban mall
into a place of communal joy we see this
whether the crew is ripping down a
public fountain in a kayak
shredding down a ski slope bare-chested
and on a surfboard or
using shopping carts for all types of
extremely reckless behavior
[Music]
and for the lucky civilians who are
privy to these disruptions
such moments can create feelings of
shock wonder joy and surprise
this is perhaps most evident during the
recurring stunt where preston
lacey a not small gentleman chases wee
man
a not large gentleman through the street
while they are both in their underwear
or in a related stunt when preston walks
into a grocery store or a porta potty
and comes out as we man
multiple scholars have pointed out that
these social disruptions often take
place in the types of suburban spaces
that represent the dreams of post-war
american culture
and it was that culture that produced
the types of boredom and suburban malays
that shaped youth culture in the 80s and
90s
the very era when our jack boys became
jackman
okay that felt weird to say for our
buddy shankan
jackass grew out of the cultural
geography of the post-war suburb
it speaks of unmonitored spaces the
cheap handheld video camera the
liberalizing cultural revolution of the
1960s and feminism in the 1970s
which sent women back to school and work
and their children into an unsupervised
world of play
and where there's unsupervised play
there's bound to be
danger hi i'm michael burns welcome to
wisecrack
no i can't do it i can't do it i can't
do it i'm going i'm going home
i'm going home stop it don't stop
filming stop filming so
we have cheap consumer goods empty
suburban spaces and a lack of strict
supervision enabled by the
safety of america's sprawling zones of
strip mall wonder this all created the
perfect cultural conditions for bored
kids with skateboards to get a little
reckless and turn
bland monuments of commerce and safety
into sites of danger and transgression
which is why it's no surprise that
jackass emerged from skateboarding
culture and specifically the magazine
big brother where johnny knoxville got
his start testing stun
guns and maces on himself and indeed
much has been written about the way
skateboarding communities have reshaped
the ecology of urban and suburban
landscapes
with some cities even encouraging
skateboarding to reactivate communities
basically when the jackass gentlemen
wreak havoc in shopping malls
they infuse them with the type of
creativity and performativity that
breaks with their intended purpose
[Music]
and these acts can be seen as critiques
of the bland monotony of suburban
culture
as shankan notes just as the medieval
jester mocked the high seriousness of
the king his floppy capped the foil to
the crown
so jackass poses as the self-conscious
gesture for the court of the suburb yet
they do so with such harmless good cheer
that their terrible honesty holds the
court together
their public stunts also bring a visible
excitement and curiosity to the folks
lucky enough to be walking by or
eating lunch outside when they happen as
sociologist aisha palsani writes while
discussing the work of fellow jackass
scholar jory lagerway
these public stunts can galvanize
interaction among strangers because
nothing helps strike up conversations
amongst strangers like an elderly woman
who is a man in prosthetics
showing up in an outdoor cafe naked this
might be a leap on my behalf but this
type of social effect
isn't too distinct from what french
jackasses jean-paul sartre and elon fat
jew
would call group subjects formed out of
novel and disruptive situations for
these french bros
something disruptive or novel happening
in a previously stagnant setting
leads to sharing wtf glances with the
strangers around us potentially bringing
us into new relations with those
strangers
okay i'll admit it i really do buy this
argument and i think it's probably the
best evidence for the show
being pretty deep there's also been some
great academic writing on this
very topic so did we exhaustively prove
that jackass is in fact a deep cultural
artifact that future generations will
use as a rosetta stone to understand the
particular contradictions of
suburban malays and the persistence of
the male adolescent ego that's not
all wrong yeah probably not and while
the aspects of the show that turn
unknowing civilians into
victims and or play on retrograde racial
and sexual tropes
definitely fall into the category of
dumb the overall artistic merit of the
show qualifies as pretty deep
especially for a group of performers
that has a designated poop
guy a jackass embraces the simplicity of
embodied performativity and finds
joy in turning generic spaces of
commerce and conformity
into sites of bizarre stunts and
spectacles and we're not the only ones
who think this as the museum of modern
art in new york
held the screening of jackass 3d as an
official event
and i would pay infinity dollars to have
been in the room as some stuffy art
types saw
all that puke and piss in 3d
and maybe one of the best testaments to
jackass's deepness is the continued
legacy of this type of body-based humor
and performativity
in folks from sasha baron cohen to eric
andre and natalie palamides but what do
you think
is jackass secretly brilliant or am i
just looking for an excuse to watch
grown men roll down a hill inside giant
tires and feel smart
let us know in the comments and before
we go we wanted to take a second to
answer some questions submitted by our
patrons on our discord
something you can be a part of for as
little as five dollars a month
just saying not david asks can you help
me understand
locke's essay concerning human
understanding
even if just book two okay so basically
qualities are things that help us
perceive and understand stuff in the
world and
substance is the raw stuff that helps us
experience things and get ideas in our
minds
but also you should read his enquiries
as they're much
more clear okay greg powell 419
asks do you believe knowing and
understanding philosophy
can lead people to become virtuous so
some of the kindest people i've ever met
haven't read a book since high school
and some of the meanest have been
distinguished philosophy professors i
think
knowing stuff doesn't make you a good
person it's the desire to be virtuous
mixed with philosophical knowledge that
gets the job done
this is what the ancient greeks were
really good at that and drinking wine
okay finally snake metro asks how can
entertainment be
vulgar and gross out humor without it
lowering the medium
okay not to be that guy but i think the
video you just watched
hopefully helped answer this a little
bit also check out our video on eric
andre but the main thing is if the
vulgar or gross thing is trying to get
laughs
just because it's gross it's usually
lowering things but the previously
mentioned sasha baron cohen and natalie
palimidi's
show us how gross and vulgar humor can
be used to make us think
about some heavy [ __ ] okay that's it for
now if you want to join in next time go
to patreon.com
wisecrack and join in on the fun as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
later
[Music]
you